Welcome back. What we are going to do now
is we are going to look at recursive
types. When we
looked at type synonyms, we tried
to declare
a recursive type synonym, but we noticed
that
that didn't work. And then I explained
when you want to create a recursive
type, it has to go
via a nominal type. And what we are
going to do
in this part of the lecture, is we are
going to look at
a few recursive types.
And the recursive type that we are
going to look at
first, is the type of natural numbers
of integers. If you recall
the lecture on recursive functions, what
we did
there when we defined a recursive
function over integers
we said: an integer can be either zero
or it could be the successor of an
integer, and since we don't have
n+k patterns anymore in Haskell,
we would have to write
n-1 on the right hand side. But if we
represent
integers in this way, we can write
nice recursive functions on these two
cases.
It is either Zero or the successor of a
natural number.
So a natural number is either Zero
or it is one more than
another natural number. And if you look
at the
types of the constructors: Zero is a
function that takes no arguments and
returns a natural number
and Succ is a function that takes a
natural number
and returns another natural number. That's
the types you see there
on the bottom.
So if we look
at all the values of this type Succ
you will see that it starts at Zero, that
is the base case, then we have Succ Zero
and Succ (Succ Zero)
et cetera. I mentioned before that we are
glossing over
certain details here, because one of
the values
that we can also have is
undefined, but since this is just an
introductory
course, I'm not going to talk about
undefined and bottom.
And typically it is
perfectly safe to do. This is the
infinite set of values in type
Nat.
As I said:
this recursive type represents
numbers and what we can do is we can
take an instance
of this Nat type and map it
to an integer. And the way we do that
is we can
turn every occurrence of the Succ
constructor into 1
and every occurence of Zero into 0.
And you see that we maintain the same
structure
and we add those up and we get 3.
So what we can do
is you see that this is a homomorphism
from
Nat to integers and
we can define that just like we defined
foldr
over lists, we can define this
function
using foldr over natural numbers.
For now
we are going to do it recursively. So
here is a function that goes from
Nat to Int. nat2int of Zero is 0
and nat2int of n+1
is
nat2int of n plus 1.
And we can go the other way around. If we
get an integer
we can get a natural number.
0 becomes Zero and here you see
where I miss n+k patterns
n becomes the Succ
of int n-1. It would be much nicer
if this would be
n+1 is the Succ of int2nat of n.
But we have to
respect the decisions that the
current Haskell committee makes.
What you can do is you can try to
prove
that these functions are inverses and
then you can show that Nat
is isomorphic to Int.
And of course we are
shoveling the fact that there are
bottoms involved here under the carpet.
Given two naturals, we can
add them up by first converting them to
integers
and then converting them back to Nats.
That is
really brute force.
We have these natural numbers
we are going to convert them to integers,
add them up and then convert the result
back.
So we take a natural number,
convert it to an integer
take the other one, convert it to an
integer, add them up
convert it back. That is not very
efficient, so instead
we can define this directly
by induction over the natural numbers.
If we
add Zero to n, that is the same as n
and if we add m+1 to n
that is m plus n plus one.
And that is the definition that you see
here. So I think this one is much more
elegant
than this one, but they are
equivalent. If we
execute an example, so we want to add
two
to one. Let's see:
We recursively
push the addition inside and
take one of these Succs outside.
We do that several times, so you see
that the add gets pushed pushed pushed
inside until it hits the
Zero. And that's Zero and there we go.
If we add two plus one
we get three.
So that was the end of part 2
and I'll see you in a few minutes
where we are going to talk about
type classes.